hi my name is Jeff I'm an Android
engineer working on applications I want
to tell you about my favorite features
of the a android phone my first favorite
feature is the favorite types of
contacts it shows you at the top your
contacts that are starred and then below
the ones you frequently contacted then
if you go to the Contacts tab and you
want to find someone say will you can
just type on the keyboard and it will
filter down and show you that person
another neat thing about the Contacts
tab is you can change the group that
you're displaying so if you have a group
set up in gmail you can go here you can
select the group and it will only show
you people who are in that group another
feature I really like is if you press
the green button twice it calls back the
last person you talked to